dans la vidéo d'aujourd'hui on va
regarder une notion qui est essentielle
en physique et en particulier en
relativité générale et qui est
malheureusement souvent abordé d'une
façon très étrange qui la rend plus
complexe que ce qu'elle n'est réellement
et qui élue d'un peu la beauté
l'élégance mathématique de cette notion
c'est la notion de tenseur alors vous
avez peut-être des gens entendu ce mot
tenseur en relativité on trouve
plusieurs exemples de danseurs le
tenseur métrique le tenseur de Riemann
le tenseur de Ricci et ainsi de suite et
c'est en sœurs ce sont des objets qui
sont très utiles pour décrire des
propriétés géométriques et en
particulier en relativité générale pour
décrire la géométrie de l'espace-temps
et pour cette vidéo je pense qu'il est
important d'abord de commencer par
démonter entre guillemets des
définitions qui sont qu'on entend
souvent et qui sont fausses ou plutôt
qui ne sont pas rigoureuses et qui
peuvent donner une mauvaise image de ce
qui est réellement un tenseur
donc la première définition entre
guillemets d'un tenseur qu'on entend
c'est que un tenseur ce serait la
généralisation d'une matrice en
plusieurs dimensions donc on aurait les
nombres qui sont simplement voilà des
nombres à 0 dimensions puis on aurait
les vecteurs qui sont des sortes de
colonnes avec plusieurs nombres de dons
donc un peu comme des lignes à une
dimension puis on aurait les matrices
qui sont des sortes de carrés ou de
rectangles avec donc deux dimensions de
des ensembles de nombres à deux
dimensions et puis tous ces objets
seraient des tenseurs d'ordre 0 1 2 qui
représente en fait la dimension de ses
tenseurs et donc un tenseur d'ordre 3 ce
serait une sorte de matrice cubique donc
on peut imaginer voilà une sorte de cube
qui aurait une dimension supplémentaire
donc un axe comme ça en plus d'être une
matrice à deux dimensions
ce serait voilà une sorte d'objet à
trois dimensions comme ça donc c'est un
peu difficile à dessiner mais on peut
imaginer une sorte de cube voilà remplie
de nombres et ça c'est une idée qui est
assez répandue lorsqu'on aborde la
notion de tenseur pour la première fois
et je sais personnellement que la
première fois que j'ai entendu le mot
tenseur et que je suis allé chercher sur
internet c'est ça que j'avais compris je
pensais qu'un tenseur c'était la
généralisation simplement d'une matrice
à plus de dimension
en fait ça c'est complètement faux
puisque c'est ensemble de nombres et
bien ça n'est simplement que des
ensembles de nombres et ça ne représente
rien de géométrique je peux tout à fait
imaginer une liste de nombres comme ça
qui ne représente pas un vecteur
c'est-à-dire une flèche dans un espace
où une matrice comme ça qui en fait ne
représente pas une application linéaire
ça pourrait être juste une sorte de
liste de nombres comme un tableau Excel
qui n'a rien de géométrique donc en fait
ceci n'est capsule pas du tout la la le
caractère géométrique de ce qu'est un
penseur donc cette définition n'est pas
du tout valable
c'est plus subtil que ça
la deuxième définition un peu plus
sophistiquée et peut-être un peu plus
valable ce serait qu'un penseur c'est un
ensemble de nombres donc comme une
matrice comme on l'a vu tout à l'heure
donc par exemple un tenseur t d'ordre 2
qui serait une sorte de matrice avec des
nombres
on peut représenter ces nombres par des
indices donc disons que les lignes sont
indexées par un indice MU et puis les
colonnes sont indexées par un indice nu
et bien ce tenseur chacun chacune de ces
entrées chacun des nombres qui le
composent serait noté tes menus et
l'idée c'est que si on change de
coordonnées pour décrire notre notre
espace dans des coordonnées différentes
et bien le nouveau tenseur donc les
nouveaux nombres qui constituent ce
tenseur sont égaux au tenseur précédent
mais multiplier par des changements de
variables et matrices de changement de
variables associées donc ce serait DX
alpha sur DX prime MU et dxbeta sur DX
prime nu voilà donc ça si vous avez pas
vu cette définition ça n'est pas très
important mais si vous avez rencontré
cette définition et bien il faut savoir
que cette définition ne permet pas de
comprendre réellement ce qu'est un
tenseur et si on aborde les tenseurs de
cette façon là même si ça permet de
faire des calculs et que c'est
effectivement valable ça laisse
complètement de côté la beauté
géométrique de ce qu'est un penseur et
puis ça laisse sous-entendre quand on
sort pour définir ce qu'est un tenseur
il faut forcément des coordonnées vous
voyez qu'ici on a forcément la notion de
coordonnées dans la définition même de
ce que serait un penseur
et donc on pourrait pas définir un
tenseur sans avoir de coordonner dans
notre espace et en fait ça c'est faux un
tenseur ça ne dépend pas des coordonnées
justement c'est beau parce que c'est un
objet géométrique qui ne dépend pas des
coordonnées donc cette définition elle
est aussi sur sa faim
alors qu'est-ce que c'est un tenseur
pour comprendre ce qui est un tenseur il
faut revenir sur une notion qui est la
notion de vecteur donc on a tous déjà vu
la notion de vecteur au lycée si vous
imaginez un espace disons le plan par
exemple le plan R2
et bien un vecteur c'est une flèche on
peut le représenter comme une flèche
dans cet espace donc on peut imaginer
plein de vecteurs comme ça qui partent
de l'origine et qui pointe une direction
et qui ont une longueur et puis si on
munie notre espace d'un repère comme ici
et de coordonner disons X et Y avec une
certaine graduation
et bien on peut décrire nos vecteurs par
des coordonnées donc ce vecteur ci par
exemple et bien je peux le décomposer
comme étant
trois unités selon la coordonnée x et
5 unités selon la coordonnée y voilà
donc je peux le noter comme étant 3,5
ce vecteur ci quant à lui et bien si je
prolonge ma graduation ce serait par
exemple moins une unité vers la gauche
donc selon les X négatifs et puis trois
unités disons vers les Y
et de cette façon au lycée on a cette
sorte de d'équivalence entre des
vecteurs des objets géométriques dans un
espace c'est flèches et puis des
ensembles de nombres comme ça des des
matrices colonnes avec des nombres
dedans qui représentent les coordonnées
des vecteurs et donc au lycée en fait on
ne fait pas trop la distinction entre
ces deux ailes et ces deux objets et on
pourrait avoir tendance à penser que
ceci est ceci c'est la même chose
et c'est là que vient la distinction
très importante c'est que le vecteur
c'est cet objet et ça n'est pas cet
objet un vecteur c'est un objet
géométrique c'est un élément d'un espace
vectoriel donc tout ça c'est un espace
vectoriel un vecteur c'est simplement un
des éléments dans cet espace donc c'est
une des flèches dans cet espace alors
que cet objet là qui est simplement un
couple de deux nombres et ça pourrait
décrire n'importe quoi ça pourrait être
par exemple je sais pas un nombre de
pommes de terre et un nombre de carottes
en fait ça n'a pas forcément de sens
géométrique cet objet là il n'a de sens
que parce qu'on s'est fixé un repère et
donc en se fixant ce repère on peut
décrire l'objet géométrique quel est le
vecteur par ces nombres abstraits
cette distinction est très importante ça
ça n'est donc pas un vecteur c'est
simplement la représentation abstraite
sous la forme de nombres de ce qu'est le
vecteur géométriquement et si je change
de repère si j'avais pris un repère
comme ça disons donc exprime
y prime et bien on voit très bien que
les composantes de mon vecteur de ma
flèche
serait différente ici la projection ne
serait pas la même sur l'axe X prime
mais sur l'axe Y prime et puis j'aurais
pu prendre des graduations qui sont
espacées différemment donc ici on aurait
par exemple deux graduations selon
exprime et puis disons une graduation
selon y prime j'aurais eu des
coordonnées différentes mais mon vecteur
n'a pas changé pour autant c'est
simplement le repère et donc le choix
arbitraire de description que je fais de
mon espace qui a changé
le point essentiel c'est donc qu'on n'a
pas besoin d'un repère
pour définir des vecteurs les vecteurs
ce sont simplement des objets dans un
espace vectoriel un espace vectoriel
c'est littéralement un espace dans
lequel on trouve des vecteurs et le
repère on a besoin uniquement si on veut
décrire ces vecteurs par des nombres
pour faire des calculs par exemple
mais alors qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un
espace vectoriel et bien un espace
vectoriel c'est défini par plusieurs
propriétés c'est un espace un ensemble
qui contient des éléments qu'on appelle
les vecteurs et puis ces vecteurs ils
ont deux propriétés c'est qu'on peut les
multiplier par un nombre donc on peut
prendre un vecteur disons ce vecteur V
et on peut prendre lambda fois V ou
lambda est un nombre alors si notre
espace vectoriel est un espace vectoriel
associé à l'ensemble des nombres réels
et bien ce lambda doit être un nombre
réel par exemple et donc je peux prendre
un nombre réel et le multiplier par mon
vecteur ça me donnera un nouveau vecteur
donc imaginons que lambda vaut 2 et bien
j'aurai le vecteur devait
donc j'ai le droit de faire ça de
multiplier les vecteurs par un nombre et
puis la deuxième propriété fondamentale
de ce qu'est un espace vectoriel c'est
que je peux additionner deux vecteurs
entre eux donc je peux prendre deux
vecteurs disons U et V et les
additionner donc ce vecteur là c'est u
les additionner de sorte avec toutes les
propriétés intéressantes de l'addition
donc le fait que l'addition est
commutative je peux faire u + V ou v+u
ça donnera la même chose et ainsi de
suite donc ici si je prends u + V bien
simplement je vais reporter le vecteur U
à la fin du vecteur V
et puis ça me donne ce vecteur ci voilà
donc ce vecteur là c'est le vecteur
u + V
et donc n'importe quel ensemble d'objets
qui satisfont ses propriétés là que je
peux multiplier par un nombre et que je
peux faire une addition entre les
éléments et bien c'est un espace
vectoriel et j'ai des vecteurs à
l'intérieur
on sait donc désormais ce qu'est un
espace vectoriel un espace de vecteur
est-ce qu'on peut imaginer sur cet
espace de vecteur c'est une opération
inventer une opération on va l'appeler t
par exemple et dire que cette opération
prend plusieurs vecteurs donc disons
qu'elle en prend deux u et v
et qu'elle retourne un nombre donc un
nombre réel en particulier si notre
espace vectoriel et basé sur le corps
des nombres réels
on peut inventer comme ça une opération
et donc ça veut dire que dans mon espace
de vecteur si je prends deux vecteurs
U et V et bien je peux regarder quel est
le résultat de cette opération t lorsque
je l'applique au vecteur UV
et alors on a vu qu'il y a deux
propriétés intéressantes dans l'espace
des vecteurs c'est la multiplication par
un nombre et puis l'addition des
vecteurs donc ce qu'on peut faire c'est
demander que notre opération elle
satisface ces deux propriétés donc
demandez que si je multiplie l'un des
vecteurs le résultat de l'opération donc
disons que je multiplie u par lambda je
veux que le résultat de l'opération se
soit lambda fois
l'opération appliquée à UV et je demande
simplement que cette opération là que
pour l'instant je n'ai pas défini
satisface cette propriété d'être elle
aussi multipliée par le nombre lorsque
je multiplie le vecteur auquel elle
s'applique ça pourrait s'appliquer aussi
à V si je multiplie à V par un autre
nombre MU et bien le résultat ici serait
également multiplié par mieux
la deuxième propriété des vecteurs c'est
que je peux les additionner et donc je
peux demander également que et bien mon
opération appliquée à une somme de
vecteurs disons
u + W un troisième vecteur W
et V ce soit la somme de l'opération
appliquée à UV
plus l'opération appliquée à double V et
vous voyez ici en fait j'ai distribué la
somme dans mon opération et cela c'est
vraiment la définition de ce qu'est un
tenseur un tenseur ça n'est qu'une
opération qui prend des vecteurs qui
donnent un nombre et qui satisfait les
propriétés de linéarité c'est à dire que
si on multiplie l'un des vecteurs et
bien ça multiplie le résultat et puis si
on additionne deux vecteurs et qu'on
applique cette opération c'est pareil
qu'additionner le résultat de
l'opération appliquée aux deux vecteurs
alors ici j'ai pris un tenseur qui prend
deux vecteurs en entrée mais ça pourrait
être un tenseur qui prend trois vecteurs
ou 4 vecteurs et ainsi de suite et c'est
ça qu'on appelle l'ordre du tenseur donc
ceci ce serait un tenseur d'ordre 2
c'est-à-dire un tenseur qui prend deux
vecteurs en entrée
pour être parfaitement rigoureux un
tenseur ça peut également prendre ce
qu'on appelle des vecteurs dans l'espace
dual c'est une subtilité mathématique et
en réalité ça ne change pas trop
l'intuition qu'il faut se faire d'un
tenseur un tenseur c'est une application
qui prend deux vecteurs ou trois ou
quatre ou un d'ailleurs et qui ressort
un nombre avec la propriété d'être
linéaire
d'ailleurs petite parenthèse ici si
j'avais additionné un vecteur sur le
deuxième vecteur et bien ça aurait
également fait la somme comme ça on
aurait distribué sur cette somme
également
bon alors jusqu'ici vous vous dites
peut-être que cette définition elle est
très étrange et qu'on ne comprend pas
trop à quoi ça sert mais en réalité je
suis sûr que si vous avez déjà vu la
notion de vecteur au lycée vous
connaissez déjà un exemple de tenseur de
cette forme là un tenseur d'ordre 2
c'est le produit scalaire le produit
scalaire c'est un tenseur puisque un
produit scalaire ça prend deux vecteurs
en entrée donc c'est bien une opération
qui prend deux vecteurs si je prends le
produit scalaire entre U et V qu'on note
u point V et bien si je multiplie l'un
des deux vecteurs disons que je prends
le vecteur lampe d'un fois U et je
prends son produit scalaire avec V c'est
pareil que de dire lambda fois le
produit scalaire de UV
donc c'est bien une opération qui valide
cette première condition et puis cette
deuxième condition et bien si je prends
la somme de deux vecteurs donc disons
u + V
produit scalaire avec un vecteur W et
bien la distributivité j'obtiens u
produit scalaire W + V produit scalaire
W donc cette deuxième condition on l'a
satisfait complètement avec le produit
scalaire le produit scalaire c'est donc
un exemple de tenseur d'ordre 2 qui
satisfait ces trois propriétés
et alors pourquoi c'était intéressant le
produit scalaire et bien justement parce
que le produit scalaire c'est quelque
chose qui nous donne des propriétés
géométriques vous souvenez peut-être si
vous avez étudié le produit scalaire au
lycée que le produit scalaire entre deux
vecteurs UV et bien ça nous donne la
norme des vecteurs U et la norme de V
multiplié par le cosinus de l'angle
entre U et V donc le produit scalaire le
résultat de l'opération il ne dépend pas
du tout du repère qu'on a choisi il
dépend que des propriétés géométriques
presque physique j'ai envie de dire des
vecteurs que sont leurs normes leur
longueur et puis l'angle qui est entre
les deux le produit scalaire son
résultat ne dépend pas du référentiel du
repère qu'on a choisi des axes et des
graduations qu'on a choisi et c'est ça
vraiment la propriété est très
intéressante d'un penseur c'est que vous
voyez dans cette définition je n'ai
jamais dit qu'il fallait choisir un
repère pour décrire un tenseur non un
tenseur c'est simplement une opération
qui prend des vecteurs et donne un et
elle est définie sur les vecteurs et non
sur leurs coordonnées
et alors au lycée on voit souvent la
définition que le produit scalaire entre
U et V ce serait simplement la somme des
coordonnées donc u coordonnées X fois V
coordonnées X + les coordonnées y des
deux vecteurs
mais quand on voit cette définition on
comprend pas trop pourquoi c'est défini
ainsi et puis ce qui est étonnant c'est
que les coordonnées dépendent du
référentiel qu'on choisit du repère
pardon donc si on choisit des axes
différents des graduations différentes
on a vu que les coordonnées varient et
pourtant le résultat ne varie pas
puisqu'il dépend que de la géométrie et
pourquoi ce résultat ne varie pas et
bien précisément parce que le produit
scalaire c'est un tenseur et ça n'est
pas juste une opération qui est définie
comme ça sur les coordonnées en
particulier cette définition qu'on voit
au lycée
ux
et bien c'est un cas particulier elle ne
marche pas tout le temps elle ne marche
que quand le repère est
orthonormé et si on changeait de repère
et bien il faudrait changer cette
formule puisque les coordonnées changent
et que le tenseur est censé donner le
même résultat
voilà donc pour résumer un tenseur c'est
une application c'est une sorte de
fonction qui prend des vecteurs qui
donnent un nombre comme résultat et qui
a toutes les bonnes propriétés de
linéarité d'addition des vecteurs et de
multiplication des vecteurs par un
nombre et le point important c'est que
le résultat du tenseur ne dépend que des
vecteurs et pas de leur coordonnées donc
pas du repère qu'on a choisi c'est
vraiment une opération sur les objets
géométriques que sont les vecteurs et
pas sur leur description abstraite leurs
coordonnées
mais bien évidemment pour faire des
calculs ces définitions un peu
géométriques elles ne sont pas pratiques
et donc on va vouloir mettre des
coordonnées faire les calculs avec des
coordonnées et c'est là que la deuxième
définition du tenseur intervient alors
comment décrire un vecteur par des
coordonnées et bien lorsqu'on a un
vecteur disons V on se munie d'un repère
donc Dax alors les axes on peut les
faire orthogonaux ils peuvent aussi ne
pas être orthogonaux là on choisit comme
on veut et puis ces axes doivent être
gradués pour pouvoir indiquer des
coordonnées pour les vecteurs là aussi
les graduations sont arbitraires un peu
graduer les axes comme on veut et on
peut leur donner des noms disons x et y
voilà
donc là mon vecteur il a des coordonnées
lorsque je projette l'objet géométrique
sur les axes est-ce qu'on peut faire une
fois qu'on a ces axes c'est tout
simplement définir des vecteurs de base
les vecteurs de base c'est des vecteurs
un peu particuliers puisque c'est les
vecteurs qui correspondent aux unités de
nos axes donc ce vecteur là qui a une
unité selon X et 0 unité sur Y je vais
l'appeler E x
c'est le vecteur de base selon X et puis
ce vecteur là
je vais l'appeler ey il a une unité sur
Y et aucune unité selon X
et à partir de ces vecteurs je vais
pouvoir décomposer n'importe quel
vecteur comme une somme de ces vecteurs
de base donc le vecteur V ici on voit
que c'est trois fois le vecteur x
puisque je donne déplacer trois fois
vers la droite et puis une deux trois
quatre fois le vecteur y puisque je dois
me déplacer 4 fois vers le haut donc
c'est trois fois le vecteur x + 4 x le
vecteur ei et c'est ces nombres ici
qu'on appelle les coordonnées les
coordonnées ce sont les facteurs
multiplicatifs qui interviennent devant
les vecteurs de base lorsque j'ai choisi
un repère donc on voit ici clairement
que si je change de repère et bien je
change de vecteurs de base et donc les
coordonnées vont changer puisque je
décris différemment mon vecteur
alors plus généralement un vecteur V
peut s'écrire comme étant ses
coordonnées que je vais noter VX et Vy
qui sont des nombres fois les vecteurs
de base ex et ey qu'on additionne alors
dans un espace vectoriel à trois
dimensions on aurait VZ
etc ici voilà pour faire simple on va
simplement prendre deux dimensions
et alors maintenant ce qui va nous
intéresser c'est prendre un autre
vecteur disons appelons le U puisque
j'ai privé donc lui aussi on peut le
décomposer avec ses coordonnées ux selon
le vecteur de base X et
uy selon le vecteur de base e y
et puis imaginons que j'ai un tenseur
d'ordre 2 T et que je l'applique au
vecteur UV donc je regarde le résultat
de mon opération t appliquée à UV donc a
priori c'est ce résultat pourrait valoir
n'importe quoi et pourtant il faut se
rappeler que UV peuvent être décomposés
de cette façon et que T ça n'est pas
n'importe quoi c'est un tenseur il doit
satisfaire certaines propriétés donc
remplaçons U et V par leur définition
et ici vous voyez que j'ai une somme
uxy et donc par propriété du tenseur par
distributivité je peux distribuer la
Somme et dire que ceci doit être égal à
T appliqué à ux
et tout ça
plus t appliqué à ce deuxième terme
uy
et tout ça
bon on va pas s'arrêter là on peut
distribuer également cette somme là
plus T2 donc ici c'est de termes là y et
y
vxx et vous avez compris plus T2
avec Vy
et d'ailleurs alors j'ai fait une petite
erreur ici j'ai mis le y en bas par
souci de rigueur pour la notation je
mets les indices en haut pour les
coordonnées et en bas pour les vecteurs
de base et donc ici Vy voilà
et alors on n'a pas besoin de s'arrêter
ici vous voyez qu'on a une autre
propriété qu'on n'a pas utilisé c'est le
fait que si je multiplie un vecteur par
un nombre et bien j'ai le droit de
sortir ce nombre du tenseur donc ici
j'ai deux nombres c'est de là c'est mes
lambda ému de ma définition de tout à
l'heure et donc je peux dire tout
simplement que ceci doit être égal assez
de nombreux
le tenseur appliqué à mes deux vecteurs
de base ex et ex
plus et bien encore une fois mets de
nombreux et y fois le tenseur appliqué à
mes deux vecteurs de base
le X et Y
encore une fois voilà
uy VX fois le tenseur appliqué aux deux
vecteurs de base
plus
uy
fois le tenseur appliqué aux deux
vecteurs de base
alors ici une petite subtilité vous
voyez que ces deux termes ici
contiennent donc ça c'est le tenseur
appliqué à X et Y ça c'est le tenseur
appliqué à y et ex dans le cas du
produit scalaire le produit scalaire
c'est un tenseur un peu particulier il
est symétrique donc l'ordre n'importe
pas et donc c'est deux objets doivent
être les mêmes mais dans le cas d'un
tenseur générique on n'a pas forcément
la symétrie et donc ces deux objets ne
sont pas forcément les mêmes
voilà et donc ça c'est le résultat alors
au début ça peut faire peur ça peut
paraître beaucoup plus complexe que ce
qu'on avait au départ mais en fait vous
voyez que c'est très intéressant
puisqu'on a simplement les coordonnées
de nos deux vecteurs
et puis ici on a des résultats
l'application du tenseur à nos vecteurs
de base et ces résultats ne dépendent
pas des vecteurs qu'on a choisi UV vous
voyez ça ne dépend que du repère qu'on a
choisi et donc des vecteurs de base donc
une fois que j'ai fixé un repère et bien
je connais je peux calculer le tenseur
appliqué à mes deux vecteurs de base
comme ça une fois que j'ai calculé ces
quatre résultats et bien je peux
utiliser ces quatre résultats pour
calculer l'application du tenseur à
n'importe quel vecteur simplement en
rajoutant leurs coordonnées et en
ajoutant comme ça
donc en particulier si on prend un
repère orthonormé et qu'on s'intéresse
aux produits scalaires au tenseur qui
est le produit scalaire le produit
scalaire de ex avec lui-même ça vaut 1
donc ça ça vaut 1 le produit scalaire de
y avec lui-même ça vaut 1 donc ça aussi
et puis le produit scalaire de ex avec
ey ça vaut 0 puisque les deux sont
perpendiculaires donc ça ça saute et ça
ça saute et vous voyez qu'on obtient
donc
que le produit scalaire de U et V c'est
ux fois VX
plus
uy fois Vy
donc là c'est très beau on a retrouvé la
définition du produit scalaire qu'on
voit au lycée c'est la somme des
produits des coordonnées mais ça ça ne
vient pas de nulle part ça devient
vraiment des propriétés géométriques de
ce qu'est le produit scalaire c'est à
dire intenseur
donc en particulier ici on pourrait
faire un tableau en comptabilisant ces
quatre termes ici puisque ces quatre
termes lorsqu'on a choisi un repère il
décrivent vraiment notre tenseur vous
voyez qu'ensuite on a juste à ajouter
les coordonnées des vecteurs qui nous
intéressent donc celui là on peut
l'appeler txx celui là TX y celui-ci
était y X et puis ce dernier là Ty
et donc là le tenseur on peut le
représenter sous la forme d'une matrice
et c'est pour ça qu'on a un peu cette
confusion souvent entre la
représentation matricielle d'un tenseur
et le tenseur lui-même cette matrice
tout comme cet objet là ça n'est pas le
vecteur c'est simplement ça
représentation abstraite et bien cette
matrice c'est simplement la
représentation abstraite de mon tenseur
lorsque j'ai choisi ces axes là xy et
donc que je peux calculer le tenseur
appliqué au vecteur de base
et enfin comme pour un vecteur si je
change de repère si je change de vecteur
de base et bien les termes dans la
matrice vont changer les coordonnées de
mon tenseur vont changer mais le tenseur
lui-même en tant qu'objet géométrique
n'a pas changé